I'm transforming myself into an old man
and starting again from scratch and the
idea is to become financially free in
just seven days be a man tell me the
truth would you actual twet she doesn't
show this will be literally challenge
over if you think that sounds impossible
like most people do and stick
[Music]
around I recently found out that the
average pensioner only has
£23 85 p a week for everything so that
is the budget that I'm allowed to spend
to live I haven't got anything booked
I'm going to be swapping my car out for
an old Banger right now I'm getting some
clothes that are going to match with my
disguise yeah that type of thing I think
that's this is just perfect oh
damn that hat is brilliant fits me quite
nice so how exactly am I going to become
financially free as my 65-year-old Alias
Tim James in the UK a salary of
£24,000 would be considered to be a
pretty average starting point this is my
goal by the end of the week I want to
set up a business that makes me at least
£2,000 per month in completely passive
income as a property developer I know
from my experience the quickest way to
do this is by controlling just a couple
of properties with the rent to rent
strategy now this strategy takes some
startup Capital so the first part of my
week is going to be about making upwards
of
£5,000 by selling property deals to
investors which I can then use to fund
my rent to rent
developments so I'm leaving my house in
buckinghamshire I'm going to go to like
the middle of England Birmingham that
kind of area wolver Hampton the houses
are quite cheap down there so I think
it'll be a bit easier to start out with
[Music]
nothing
so first things first is I need to find
networking events so I'm going to book
as many as I can for tomorrow and then
just rock up in my old man
disguise
and find people that want property
Investments it looks like there's
absolutely loads I can't spend too long
looking at all these because I've got to
be up in like almost 6
hours
[Music]
all right how am you
wow you look like your granddad all
right how are you mate that's sick
where's my car at bro is it this one
no this is it then this is it
[Music]
mate you're having a laugh mate this
tries terrible how can we make money
together property investors yeah I do
land I want you to be able to go back to
Sonia and say Sonia I met this guy
called Tim Jones he's going to blow up
your legal practice so how could we work
together then that's what I want to know
how do you work within the state agent
I've got a property investment company
but yeah I'm potentially looking at some
land this week I'll buy from an agent
all day long should I email it over if I
come if I see some this week if I was to
find a propor would I be able to pass it
over to you guys and get it wrapped up
within like 6 weeks I am looking to
connect property investors with property
investment deals business happening at
BNI s so you need to ring con and that's
for the director in charge of that
office I'm going to write that down and
I'll tell them that I was sent by Big
Daddy Big Daddy of the
family I don't think it could have gone
much better considering that I just
rocked up without even paying any money
John the architect told me that
son-in-law works at Connells so I'm
going to go to Connells I've got like a
nice in there I reckon I'm going to go
to this one last networking event and
then I'm going to then start hitting the
phones going in agencies this car feels
like it's his capacity I'm in the
highest gear and it's struggling it's
like
one what kind of a deal are you looking
for R rank deals we are out so if I
bring you something how soon do you
reckon You' be able to get it completed
within 2 days 2 weeks two days oh I was
going to say Man 2 weeks these are
houses my fee is
3,000 I do require payment once you've
sort of secured it sounds
perfect so it's been a great day I've
got the investors ready now I need to
find the deals but when I'm going out to
the estate agents tomorrow I just don't
want anyone to know know that I'm Samuel
lead so today I sensed there was a few
people giving me funny looks I got a
couple of
Winks the
disguise so to remain anonymous and keep
the challenge Fair I've decided to make
a big
sacrifice do you know any property
investors real estate if I find
something this week suitable I'll email
you and then if it looks good just give
me a call and we can do some business
all right thank you brother thanks for
the cut too
my goal today is to make £3,000 to do
that I need to get one deal closed I'm
really excited about one of the
investors that I met yesterday I was
networking I sat down I didn't say
anything I just said you go first and
you know what she said she said I'm an
investor based in Birmingham looking for
a deal sorcer and I was just like hello
in terms of payment and stuff as well
assuming that the deal works and you
like it are you in a position to pay
today or where where are you at with
with with that sort of things I've
already kind of put the fee to the side
because I've been waiting for this
opportunity to come so I already have it
so if I need to make payment today I'm
fully prepared that's awesome all right
thank you so much I'll see you soon all
right thank you soon cheers
bye boom she'll pay she will definitely
pay
hello I'm just ringing about a property
on for rent my name's Tim Tim James is
it still available is it it's actually
not hey how you doing my name is Tim
James I'm looking for a property to buy
that's in need of serious repair yeah he
not on the market anymore
sorry all right mate how are you my name
is Tim James looking for property deals
his property is gone he's rented I was
looking forward to being your best ever
customer what right mate my name's Tim
James it looks like he's been on the
market since last year yeah because we
can't get e your Tim jams oh it's rented
that's a shame I can't make Saturday
unfortunately what about today all right
then thanks for calling thank no worries
thank you so much for
nothing
finding property deals today has been a
nightmare so far so to boost morale I'm
going to surprise a very special lady in
my
life I wondered if I could have a look
at your scooter by any chance yeah who
told you your grandson told me which
one this one it's
not hello Grandma come for a
cuddle why did you look so
different why do you look so different
hey you should have seen him I was
shocked I saw this person at the front
door and I thought this man who is he
and I didn't know whether it was a real
scammer that was going to knock me on
the head you look so different and you
look old nearly as old as me ja's going
to be able to complete the challenge
absolutely whether they anybody Rec him
or not he'd still do it because he has
got such tenacity for anything and
everything oh thanks yes you're awesome
it
there I need to go into Connells what
was the guy's name Lee from Connells
that John connected me
to feeling energized I'm ready to get
property deals and win this challenge I
know you're right hi there yeah I don't
know if Lee's in today believe he's out
on appointments at the moment so you've
had a discussion with Lee before about
looking to buy a property have you yeah
I'm looking for an investment something
that needs a bit of work on street it's
a decent house to be fair that's great
thank you Courtney no problem at all I
keep like name dropping Lee and
obviously Lee is their boss so they were
like oh oh oh oh Le oh you know Le I
never even met Lee but he's opening so
many doors for me right now which is
just crazy it's not just what you know
it's also who you know and sometimes who
you don't
know I've secured my first viewing let's
see if it's a winner and if it is I will
try selling this deal to the investor I
met at the networking event and get my
£3,000 commission least needs a little
bit of work this one is good bit of an
understand well this one is
a good old Reb perfect so this will be
perfect effect by refurbish Finance deal
just in case you're working out how much
the referb is going to be and with all
the structual problems it's difficult to
know so stop digging into it I mean I'm
pretty good I'm pretty handy but there's
a limit so this deal it's not bad if it
didn't have structural issues it would
be perfect the problem is the structural
problems and I'm not strict engineer but
I I wouldn't feel comfortable trying to
package and sell that deal to an
investor so we've got another view to go
to with the vendor which is not even on
the market it was on the market it sold
it fell through they've not put it back
on the market so fingers crossed this
Vie will go a bit better we'll see oh
it's quite spacious though yeah so I got
some cracks here normally I would just
send I would just take a picture and
send it over to my structure engine here
but obviously I'm King James I need to
do everything myself right now hello I'm
just ringing about a promise that I just
viewed my name's Tim that one I think
that kind of works you know I I
definitely will put in an offer it's
it's a little bit below 159 as well so I
don't know whether they'll accept it but
hey I'll throw it in see what happens
thanks Corner in a bit bye come on oh
I'm loving this so I'm putting offers
forward now so that property is a
pre-auction property which means that
the seller is really motivated so I'm
going to uh yeah wait to see what
happens with that one next another
viewing to go to my M let's
go too big for me so you wouldn't want
to be extending it as it is upstairs
four bedrooms and then this one is the
office and then there's a fourth bedroom
at the back yeah good sizes cuz I
actually got another house in orridge
that's on the market would you consider
selling both of them at the same time to
to me that's what I'm doing I'm trying
to sell both of them would you be able
to move reasonably quickly or are you
possibly yeah possibly love that here's
the thing right not only could you get
two Flats out of that easy it used to be
too flat but also look at the whole
street see how they've all extended
above apart from this house I'm going to
go to the next VI right now and at least
get a drive by let's see what we can do
do you think 185 do you think that would
be a go or do you think they'd accept it
I would like to think so yes yeah all
right thanks so much come on this is
beginning to get a bit easy momentum's
on site
[Music]
baby okay good news the offer has been
accepted on the two properties now I
just need to find the investors so
you'll always have problems but the
problems will change invest a finding
[Music]
time I'm going to ring some of the guys
I met yesterday at the networking events
that told me they were specifically
looking for fixer up of properties and
I'm just going to see can they put their
money where their mouth is hey what's
going on man you said that you
interested in uh me sourcing you a deal
bro so uh I just thought I'd give you
your call and see how I can help all
right great my finders fees is £3,000
does that sound reasonable to you for
for for for what we're talking yeah I'm
going to make £1,000 a month I think
yeah okay shall I send you over uh a
copy of the terms and conditions if it
works for you and if you want to get if
you want to if you want to move on it
just transfer over the money okay I'm
very 50/50 he sounded almost sounded hot
but I didn't agree % I'll keep
calling what what do you want from me
then bro you mentioned that you were
looking to sell me and the um business
partner might be interested in taking it
off your hands I've got a deal in
erdington birming I can send you all the
pictures and the links and everything
like that I can send you an invoice and
then and then um and then yeah have a
look at it and if it all looks good then
you can get it get it all signed and
sent back that's brilliant thank you
very much for your time you're welcome
speak you
soon
[Music]
there's a property course going on
around here so I thought well let's see
what's going on property entrepreneur
pprint that's got my name written all
over it I still got one more deal to
sell Ste so see if I can sell it right
now I've got too many properties that I
know what to do with in terms of
opportunities so I'm potentially looking
to start deal selling so I've got a
proper company uh Birmingham
bamp cuz I've got deals I've got a lot
of properties yeah that's why I'm here
came here to sort of learn a bit more
about employing people and growth I've
got a property just found the road
£200,000 purchase £50,000
spend and value 325 if I can find an
investor all right well we'll hopefully
do business then yeah see so are you how
do you feel about the general concept of
everything are you comfortable with
everything do you have any questions for
me I'm comfortable with everything um
don't have any questions I feel like
everything has kind of beening I
understand everything I just want to
move forward and get this that's cool so
the sourer this is the like the
background I.E the reason for the
agreement once you've paid the sources
fee that's when we'll go and go to town
on giving you all the information all
the documents if at that point you say
you know what I know I've paid but I'm
not comfortable you are entitled to a
full refunded so you've got a 14-day
calling off period And if you want to
sign just
here well congratulations thank you
great
deal I was really starting to make some
progress but my luck was just about to
run out can I have a we just wanted to
check you were part of the event well I
thought it was a free networking event I
I just something's not right so I'd
obviously like you to leave not for
another 5 minutes or I think you're
bullshitting that's I so what do you
want me to do tell me the truth be a man
that's what I want you to tell me I'm
staying here I came to the reception and
they told me there was a poty event and
I thought it looked a great with people
something doesn't feel right about this
whole situation so if you're not going
to be honest with me about what you're
doing
then it's Conversation Over isn't it I
guess
okay well I hope you guys W after the
event organizers had repeatedly asked me
to leave I recognized someone at the
door at my last ditch attempt at getting
back in the room thank
you oh my goodness oh my
goodness man could I get aelfie with you
is that
okay I'm a massive
F you keep nice and quiet boy you keep
my nice to see
you I saw there was a property
networking event went in got paid my
£3,000 and then a guy came over and said
have you paid for this event and I was
like um Oh I thought it was I thought it
was
free he said you're a liar you're a
bullshitter he kicked me out in the most
brutal way ever see you that belfrey we
enjoyed your free
[Music]
drinks
yes
£3,000 and my other dude is paid that's
crazy
£6,000 in Tim James's
Bank oh man I'm going to sleep good
tonight I've never felt so excited about
about £6,000 in my entire
life I've got to check out my hotel
today to be honest I'm not really
bothered about checking out my hotel I
hate this hotel you might think I'm
being anal I got stung by a wasp late
last night so I basically being a
prisoner in this room my plan today is
to get my own properties on rent to rent
I got six grand in my account which is
incredible now I need to invest that to
become financially free so what I'm
going to be doing is I'm going to be
calling properties like look at this
this is a little studio flat to me
that's not our studio flat that is a
hotel room but if I could rent that out
for £100 a night £00 a night is 3 Grand
a month so I want to turn that little
Studio into a mini hotel that's the plan
today rent to
rent how much long do you think it will
take um just another 10 minutes okay I'm
just really concerned about the time we'
been doing this for hours once some
deals there it it goes you understand my
brows feel fine need to get some deals
now and it's like after 10:00 so I'm
[Music]
stressed this is pushed now very pushed
oh
[Music]
sugar oh what oh was panicking for a
minute ke good morning can I have a chat
with somebody from L do you rent a
companies bringing about the commercial
property for sale don't really get
involved with company lets or sharers we
don't unfortunately anymore do you do
the rent to rent model we're just not
interested I don't know whether they'd
be open to a to a purchase lease op but
most that come to don't accept
compy hard to just get a hold of
somebody need to get some things
confirmed today that be looked at asting
all of their landlords don't do company
LS not one right we have suspended
viance on that property as a company now
we've decided to stop doing company
after contacting dozens of latting
Agents none of them seem to want to give
me a company letter or rent to rent my
Lu needs to change
fast Tim speaking How can I
can you do half 4 uh halfast 4 yeah I
could do half past 4 boom viewing with
Luke oh now I another
confirmation viewing confirmation
viewing confirmation this is beginning
to pick up
good I feel a bit
stressed why am I stressed it's just Tim
James if everything goes to [__] this
week Tim
James I'm going to park here
and walk to the house because if I see
the car I genuinely think they might not
give me a company that on the house
because they about how can you afford
the rent but you can't even afford a
decent car so let's walk the rest of the
way the rental Market's really hot so
trying to get rental propy STS up is
different from trying to buy thank you
for showing us around so this landlord
then yes he's open to a company he has
been a landlord before he is open to a
company depending on what other offers
are received for this he's looking at
150 isn't he we'd like to put an offer
forward this one that's fine no worries
the only thing I would need you to do is
just do a holding deposit form for the
property what is the holding deposit uh
on this one 265 okay cool let the
landord know that we do want to go ahead
with this one50 thank so much thank you
very much I've sent my offer to the
landlord now it's in their hands to say
yes passive monthly income here we
come how can hell all right is Tim I'm
just ringing about uh the property that
we view landord Happ to go ahead with a
company
left okay um so we will be proceeding
with it rent to rent one down this is
beginning to get a bit easy momentum's
on side another viewing oh there's not
really much to do at all is
there to
go the other one is smaller but this one
needs less work is n it's fine yeah good
yeah no issues should I get the director
to come down in about half an hour maybe
yeah yeah that'll help yeah that's fine
yeah and then he can sign pay all right
lovely great but it's all good my end
that's good I can only afford to get two
rent to rents Max but two rent to rents
and they make me a grand each then then
then that's it that replaces an average
salary so this is coming together baby
that guy literally said come to the
office now if you want and get all the
paperwork done give you the keys it's
empty it's ready to go it it's crazy the
only thing is is he I'm going to need to
bring my photo ID and I don't have any
photo ID of Tim James so I might have to
go and actually tell them my true
identity is Samuel Leeds I don't know
what I'm going to do I'm just going to
turn up and see what happens I'm feel a
bit
nervous I've not actually paid yet I
think they're going to have to make me
jump through hoops I just feel a bit
sick actually about
this you guys what's you got on your
skin I'm the maintenance guy you put on
Prosthetics to make it look older so why
do you do that just to freak you
out I've got the contract here draw
signature well it's been a real pleasure
Sammy thanks so much I'll see you soon
boom thank you very much I love
collecting Keys I've got a saying that
says never be at ease until you got the
keys and I've been a little bit nervous
to be honest all day but I'm so glad to
get the keys to my first rent to rent I
know I'm going to make £1,000 a month
profit on this property I'm going to
turn it into a mini Hotel shout out to
all the good agents in Birmingham and
the black country that have been open to
doing company lets that have been open
to work with an old man like this I had
to reveal my identity but uh they were
all right and I think they even saw the
funny side I finally secured everything
I need to earn £22,000 passively per
month to become financially free the
only thing left to do is use my
remaining cash to turn my two houses
into luxury hotel rooms but before I do
that I thought I'd hit H the town as Tim
James to celebrate this night could get
messy 5 and 4
54 6 and 5
65 2 and 7 27 I don't get 7 and
75 do 7 and N 79 I don't i s and 71 CL
71 Maxwell 2519 this is well boring 3
and one
31 5 two
52 so I've now got two rent to rent
properties and if I'm going to turn them
into hotels effectively they need to be
fully furnished so I thought no better
place than the wonderful cheap and
cheerful Ikea land let's get this place
furnished he
[Music]
hey
where are we again how do I actually buy
this
[Music]
bed I really badly wanted that bed
unfortunately I think it's out of stock
what's the next
[Music]
best when I leave Ikea a review later
I'm going to mention your name it's not
going to be a good review but I'll still
mention your name I appreciate
it so since I've almost finished the
challenge and I've got two rent to rents
now I've been missing my wife and kids
like crazy so my wife Amanda has come to
see me she's in the restaurant with the
kids she's not seen me like this neither
of the kids I'm going to put my parents
and skills to the test now and see
whether my kids talk to strangers or not
like they shouldn't let's find
out all right would you like some Sweet
yeah can I come and sit down next to you
what's your
name h ni Ruby move along my name called
Luke your name is called Luke and J I
can move along then please I got some
sweets there you go you can have a
sweet it like a s where's your daddy oh
he's at holiday he's on holiday would
you like another sweet yeah hey Daddy
got a your daddy's got this F
yeah oh wow that's really cool got
something to tell you Ruby
Joy Ruby Joy
lud Luke Samuel
lud my gosh I am I am your
daddy I'm your daddy no he not I'm your
daddy
too my goodness what who's this man that
you're talking to they were taking sweet
for me and
everything guys you don't take sweets
from
strangers you're are daddy I'm your
Daddy can I tou
you oh it's so creepy how does it look
so real
bab
hello hello bib is that your
hair yeah I shaved it
off this one's not sure still keep that
your
[Music]
kiss
okay okay we
fit
so the lady that Elliot my friend bought
this car from he said that she was like
really struggling financially and that's
why she sold the car and she's a nurse
so I decided to come back to the house
and if she's in I'm going to knock the
door right now and I'm going to give her
the car as a gift because I don't really
need it anymore and if she's struggling
financially I felt like it was just a
nice thing to
do
oh
man I didn't even remember that the
house was sort of part furnished like
wardrobes wardrobes Chester drawers
hopefully this bed looks okay just going
and get my headboard and then time to
start flat back in been a
[Music]
while
so today I was in a little bit of a rush
because I needed a bed for me to sleep
in so I just quickly grab this but
tomorrow I'm going to finish Furnishing
all of the house and the other house get
these ready to go live as many Hotel
two rent to rents Keys collected £6,000
made and I'm ready for
bed I'm about to put this property on
booking.com Airbnb late rooms all the
different sites and hopefully fingers
crossed the bookings are going to come
in crazy it looks completely different
I'm going to show you around so you can
get a little bit of a feel for how this
looks now
so this has been converted from a house
to now like a mini Hotel so we've got
four rooms in this house the other house
is already also fully furnished and
fingers crossed I'm going to get
contractors tourists relocators business
professionals staying at this property
on a short stay
[Music]
basis so I'm going to advertise it at
around about £60 a night and we'll see
what happens if I can get an 80%
occupancy rate which is very standard
then each property should make me a ,000
a month profit I have had to lease some
of the furniture cuz I was on a little
bit of a budget which might eat up my
cash flow slightly but right now I'm
going to get it live and I want to see
if the bookings come in and see how much
cash flow and profit these properties
actually
make
so it's been 6 weeks since the Financial
Freedom Challenge and I have just had a
one month booking and the other property
is fully booked up until the very end of
the year until 2024 after all my costs
rent to the landlord my bills my channel
management fees my cleaners the profit
is just over over £22,000 per month from
just those two properties that I set up
from scratch in 7 Days starting with
zero money in a booking booking booking
booking booking booking coming through
to my phone while I'm just relaxing here
en Tire Madness Financial Freedom in 7
days it happened and I'm absolutely
[Music]
stoked let's say you can't teach an old
dog new tricks well I guess I proved
them all wrong you've just seen me from
scratch become financially free as an
old man with no money in 7 days if you
want to do the same thing too and you
want my help doing it then learn more in
the description it's your turn baby Link
in
bio